Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, we're going to talk some more about
fluid simulations and fluid guiding.
Hell yeah!
As you know all too well, it is possible to
simulate the laws of fluid motion on a computer,
make a digital scene, and create absolutely
beautiful videos such as the ones you see
here.
Newer and newer research papers show up to
both extend the possible scenarios that we
can simulate, and there are also other works
to speed up already existing solutions.
This piece of work introduces a technique
that mathematicians like to call the primal-dual
optimization method.
This helps us accomplish two really cool things.
One is fluid guiding.
Fluid guiding is a problem where we're looking
to exert control over the fluid while keeping
the fluid flow as natural as possible.
I've written my Master thesis on the very
same topic and can confirm that it's one hell
of a problem.
The core of the problem is that if we use
the laws of physics to create a fluid simulation,
we get what would happen in reality as a result.
However, if we wish to guide this piece of
fluid towards a target shape, for instance,
to form an image of our choice, we have to
both retain natural fluid flows, but still,
create something that would be highly unlikely
to happen according to the laws of physics.
For instance, a splash of water is unlikely
to suddenly form a human face of our choice.
The proposed technique helps this ambivalent
goal of exerting a bit of control over the
fluid simulation while keeping the flows as
natural as possible.
There are already many existing applications
of fluids and smoke in movies where an actor
fires a gun, and the fire and smoke plumes
are added to the footage in post production.
However, with a high quality fluid guiding
technique, we could choose target shapes for
these smoke plumes and explosions that best
convey our artistic vision.
And number two, it also accomplishes something
that we call separating boundary conditions,
which prevents imprecisions where small fluid
volumes are being stuck to walls.
The guiding process is also followed by an
upsampling step, where we take a coarse simulation,
and artificially synthesize sharp, high-frequency
details onto it.
Computing the more detailed simulation would
often take days without such synthesizing
techniques.
Kind of like with Wavelet Turbulence, which
is an absolutely incredible paper that was
showcased in none other than the very first
Two Minute Papers episode.
Link is in the video description box.
Don't watch it.
It's quite embarrassing.
And all this leads to eye-poppingly beautiful
solutions.
Wow.
I cannot get tired of this.
In the paper, you will find much more about
breaking dams, tornado simulations, and applications
of the primal-dual optimization method.
Normally, to remain as authentic to the source
materials as possible, I don't do any kind
of slow motion and other similar shenanigans,
but this time, I just couldn't resist it.
Have a look at this, and I hope you'll like
the results.
Hm hm!
If you feel the alluring call of fluids, I've
put some resources in the video description,
including a gentle description I wrote on
the basics of fluid simulation and fluid control
with source code both on the CPU and GPU,
and a link to Doyub Kim's amazing book that
I am currently reading.
Highly recommended.
If you also have some online tutorials and
papers that helped you solidify your understanding
of the topic, make sure to leave a link in
the comments, I'll include the best ones in
the video description.
If you would like to see more episodes like
this one, make sure to subscribe to Two Minute
Papers, we would be more than happy to have
you along on our journey of science.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!